prudemment mais irréversiblement je vais
boire une pinte de bière au pub
un scénario qui paraissait utopique qui
deviendra bientôt réalité
le premier ministre britannique a
annoncé ce samedi le happy mondays un
jour porteur d'espoir pour londres et le
reste du pays ce lundi en effet la
capitale britannique a débuté son
déconfinement après avoir enregistré la
veille une journée historique sans décès
liés aux kovy 19 un an après le début de
la pandémie
un déconfinement possible grâce à une
vaccination massive outre manche alors
que le royaume-uni est le pays le plus
endeuillé d'europe
le premier ministre boris johnson se
félicite de la situation sanitaire tout
en rappelant les risques liés à un
retour à la vie normale et en l'état
actuel des choses je dois absolument
rien dans les données qu'ils puissent me
dissuader de poursuivre notre feuille de
route vers la liberté
le déblocage de notre économie et le
retour à la vie que nous aimons et bien
sûr il y a beaucoup de risques
ils devront être honnête sur les
difficultés qui nous attendent après la
réouverture des écoles le 8 mars dernier
les habitants réapprivoiser leur liberté
en profitant des parcs les activités
sportives en plein air sont également
possibles golf natation tennis
les londoniens profite de la levée
progressive des restrictions
nous n'avons pas nagé depuis le 5
janvier alors nous étions très excités
de pouvoir revenir et de nous remettre
dans l'eau je suis passé devant tous les
jours j'ai pu voir le cours fermées je
suis impatient de frapper la balle
aujourd'hui c'est merveilleux absolument
merveilleux le début d'une nouvelle et
belle liberté j'espère toujours dans le
respect des règles 8 m d'euros
boris johnson devra malgré tout attendre
le 12 avril prochain pour la réouverture
des pubs et des bars les commerces non
essentiels devraient rouvrir à cette
même date
malgré les beaux jours qui se profile à
londres le secrétaire d'état à la santé
appelle à la vigilance en raison de la
hausse des nouveaux variants en europe